the Joe Rogan experience is this you
yeah oh yeah that's me with PT will you
end an Seng with the Stars yeah
oh [ __ ] yeah how hard was that to do oh
it's incredible
okay nor every what the hell is going on
here good lord he sang to her there we
did it we did it we did it Wow
yeah Randy kochenko looks like Randy was
crying what's his name uh Kevin Hart
Kevin Hart was the judge yeah
you give me a ten oh that's the only
thing I got look at look she had to
carry me off there Wow oh yeah that tore
my butt up man I imagine literally
serious [ __ ] training for that King
ref I came off that was rectal cancer
whoa I got I found out on that show Wow
how'd you don't think he got it from
dancing I think I got it from no smokin
and in the stress from no smoking weed
no smoking weed I quit smoking weed
during the show why did you do that I
thought it would help me with my
coordination or so well with me being
there listening you know yeah because
it's hard to learn things when you're
stalling something sir I'm saying it
yeah like in jujitsu most people agree
that it's not a good idea to smoke pot
when you're learning skills but it's a
good idea to smoke pot when you have the
skills yeah yeah it was coming you down
yeah when you roll and you already know
what to do it's like instinctive then
you can smoke some pot yeah but like
learning like if someone shows me a new
move and I'm high I can't even figure
out where the bodies tell I'm like
where's your honor how am i doing let's
get too high I know what am i doing you
get baffled yeah yeah well that's the
same as tango well so you really think
that that happened to us of that you see
I had prostate cancer and and it was a
kind of process it was so slow acting
lazy as doctors said well we won't do
we'll just leave it alone and you
probably died of something else before
that happens and so he's his attitude
that was there at it Jesus Christ yeah
it happens all the time you know because
you know prostate can be very slow and I
had a slow one and but I had a biopsy
when I had to find out because I was
going to do the growth hormone and
that's why I checked out my blood to
make sure you know I didn't have cancer
found out I had prostate cancer and but
they did a biopsy and I think that could
have done it you know to biopsy they can
take a piece of yours so you think that
taking a biopsy could have caused damage
which would have led to cancer could
have could have caused the cancer cell
to to hit the direct him the way it did
oh and so I got a bag now I got a cross
me bag you know and so but now I'm
totally healed now and I'm good to go
you know the only thing and so I don't
know if it was the lack of weed in in
the stress and and the fact that I had
prostate you know so when they fixed
direct oh and I got the best one of the
best doctor Kazanjian what they have to
do they had to operate they had to take
out change the plumbing from them from
the front from the back to the front
that's the class me bait so he so III
have no more rectum Wow so a virgin
again I'm kidding and then you put the
background to the front and that's all
they did there and then I had then they
but to but they did they swept prostate
clean with the radiation they said we're
down there anyway so we might as well do
their prostate too so they fixed a
prostate and thank God I never had it
taken out because now I can I got the
sleeping giant is awoke again a giant
yeah I woke the sleeping giant up I
think it was a weed that did it to it
plus my gorgeous waves but yeah I
started getting these urges and I
thought what's happening here and I'm
doing testosterone that's probably
whatever
yeah the tossin testosterone and then
and then I'm going in for a shot
tomorrow that's it's a it's a new
procedure that they use
apparently to help induce labor because
it's all about blood flow down there
mm-hmm and so it's going to do so I
tried pills I tried viagra you know it
doesn't doesn't work enough mm-hmm and
so I'm going in tomorrow for an
injection of some some help to blood so
to help the giant get a little more
awake
[Applause]